hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsensors.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong
and i've just decided guys a few months
ago to create my youtube channel
because i want to show you guys how
portrayers are actually working what
kind of tools and techniques we can use
to build up our view and to take our
positions
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and how to do it yourself
you guys are in the right place so in
today's video i want to make an update
on fubu tv
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so let's start on the daily
time frame so the daily time frame
and the four weeks time frame are the
best time frame to use games because
they are the most used by the
the most traders and this are the time
frames where you're gonna find the best
reactions
so let me sum up quickly what is the
situation here right
it looks bearish right i'm bullish i'm
bullish guys and i'm gonna explain
why so very quickly i was bearish for
the past month
and i turned bullish recently because we
reached my target how did i find my
target
i just tried to find the level where i
had the
best reactions in the past so you know
it was a bit messy
i was turning 23 21 20. all right i put
21.5
now i have my support level first thing
we just did minus seven percent on the
seventh of april
did i turn bearish no why because
two reasons first reason my support
level
is holding from a support level to be
broken
i need to have two consecutive candles
that are trading below on the daily time
frame guys very important this is on the
daily time frame and you can see here i
have one
trending below all right second one is
above
below on the 5th of april above
below on the 7th of april let's see what
is it what is the eighth of april
showing us
but i'm pretty convinced it's going to
be above this once again
is a bit approximative because as i said
i could put 21.5 i could put 20 alright
so we need to run a shorter time frame
to get
more precise levels so let's do it
and here we can find guys something very
interesting
that i like to trade that is reacting
very well
is descending triangle so what is a
descending triangle
is a triangle that you obtain so here
it's like this and downward
time frame by connecting a horizontal
basis with a downward
sloping trend line so here i have one
maximum level
then a second one so i have enough to
make my trend line and oh
look what i have i have a reactions here
guys
so this is showing me that this trend
line is used by other traders and that
is going to react
in a bullish way if we break it on the
upside same thing on the downside i have
my horizontal bases
so what we are looking for guys is a
breakout on the upside
of this downward sloping trendline of
this descending triangle
pattern once again if we have on the
four hours let's go into four hours it's
better like i said
i mean i use the one hour but guys if
you're not pro traders
stay on the four hours time frame it's
easier the one hour time frame is going
to just you know
mess up your mind here i do the same
thing on the first time frame
so my triangle is the same if we see two
consecutive candles running below
the 20.7 now we have a precise level
here on the daily time frame my level is
approximative
actually this is the level guys all
right so i can put it at 20.5
but whatever it's not very important all
right so if we have here two consecutive
candles on the fourth time frame turning
below
guys watch out maybe something is up
especially if volumes start to kick off
what i expect
is something like this so i expect we
stay in this triangle
and that suddenly bam we break it then
maybe we retest we go here
we go here and then we break this so i'm
gonna come back to this
but first thing one other indicator that
is
giving me bullish signals guys is the
macd
so the macd signal is the red bar here
is negative all right
and the macd signal is given by the macd
the difference between the magazine and
the nine day
exponential moving average of the macd
itself so it's the difference
between the blue line and the orange
line that
you can see here and guys when we have
this consolidation
pattern here this small descending
triangle
the blue line you can see is not going
lower anymore so the macd is an average
so it's going to start to be like this
and the exponential
moving average of the macd itself is
gonna be slower so
here we're gonna have this inversion all
right so i expect to have positive
signal
on the macd on the 9th or
10th 12th of april maybe monday it's
going to turn
green for sure if we don't break the
20.7 so if we just stay
in this area this is why guys the time
horizon of your analysis is very
important to
hear just by doing nothing we are
turning bullish
the bearish momentum is slightly uh
getting out of the market
all right bears lose faith right
bulls gain confidence and this process
takes a bit of time that's why i told
you guys
that here i was bearish because you know
bears were in control
bulls got destroyed in the second move
down
i was bearish here guys because the
british momentum was too strong here the
british momentum given by the macd is
actually shifting
and this signal is going to be used by a
lot of investors that when they see a
positive magnet on the daily time frame
they start to buy shares and they are
right to do so
and this is gonna happen all right this
is not something i think
this is a fact if we don't break the
20.7
level i give you my very precise
scenario right now and let's see if i'm
correct
what's gonna happen guys is that until
the 12th of
april we keep consolidating maybe until
the 9th of april
this i can't be sure but maximum until
the 12th of april
then the macd is going to turn green
then buyers are going to step in the
game
we're going to break this descending
triangle on the short
term so we're going to have a bullish
day you know something like
plus ten plus twenty percent around nine
twelve thirteenths of april then you
take a step back
and guys this what is happening here is
happening here as well
so it's gonna be the same thing all
right until the 10th of may
where the weekly macd
okay we don't see the weekly macd very
well you see the weekly macd is still
negative
but when we gonna arrive here guys the
weekly macd
is gonna react the same way the daily
macd is acting
now so it's gonna be the same phenomenon
creating the same consequences which is
bullish flows coming into this
market technical analysis is about
reading the flows about
anticipating them about understanding
who is doing what
for what reason and i can tell you that
here some investors
are gonna buy food tv very soon i think
that
around the 10th of may we're gonna have
the huge breakout
you guys are waiting for so let's see if
this is
happening i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and that button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys